I think my first memory would probably
be in the 70s dancing in my basement
listen back in the Caribbean when we did
Calypso dancing it's basically just
moving your waist back in India five six
years old I used to dance thank you
when she was two years old she tried to
copy me to dance
never happy because with an ting I'm not
a good dancer but I always say that's
for yourself not for anybody else an
unbelieving proof of that my mom does
not really have rhythm well I look like
I do I've rhythm yes rhythm rhythm mom
singing rhythm doesn't mean you have
root is a death this is how my dad
dances boy don't
I don't know he made up something I get
no dinner tonight oh I'm going to teach
you something that everybody is doing
now because you know when we do go out
together I need you to be on what you
put one of your hands up you kind of
shake it as you step back that's that
that's really bad just shake the leg
just shakes leg-breaking oh this is
style break your legs
oh wait I have no backwards okay now I'm
getting it oh there you go oh this one
up here like you have a lasso in there
turn around so watch me first duh
no no good yeah get it like it yeah now
that I taught you some moves hey where'd
my game it's called just dance okay
we're gonna go ahead and go to the app
Just Dance and that's gonna make this
the controller for the game are you
ready okay ready okay let's do this
girl girl
ah yes whoa you were really close i won
wait did I win that's what I'm talking
about
she did good today yeah you did good
thank you the family that dances
together stays together
yeah trouble done yeah